hi my name is Matt and I got to play
some resident evil 3 remake and here's
what I think about it so right off the
bat I do have to admit I am a big fan of
the original resident evil 3 so I had a
lot of expectations going into this one
and to be honest it's pretty awesome so
it's a bit of a reimagining like
Resident Evil 2 remake but it kind of
does it way more so than that came does
result to remake you know you showed up
in the RPG and like there's all these
like familiar sights and sounds and just
sort of areas button-pressing evil 3
remake you're just out in Raccoon City
and everything about that and they the
sort of the structure of that area is
different there are different shops
there different roads alleyways pathways
through the city that completely
reimagine the original experience so
since this takes place in Raccoon City
it is a bit more open right I mean of
course you're running through the
streets in the original but in this one
sort of the areas themselves have this
more expansive quality so there are
similarities to the original resonable 3
in that it shares a lot of like you know
I somewhat identical objectives I had to
power up the substation to get a train
going to get at a raccoon city there's a
whole section in the original where you
did that but in this remake the path to
getting there is drastically different
the areas that you're exploring are not
anywhere remotely resembling the
original like you know you're going
through like a like a drug store you're
going through like these weird alleyways
and even like a 50s inspired donut shop
[Music]
one of the examples of an area that's
been replicated for the original but
totally reimagined is the actual
substation area itself the big
difference here is that instead of just
kind of showing up and just kind of
doing this slow like meter puzzle thing
zombies I think that's how it was you go
there and it is like infested with
insects they're giant insects and try to
remember if it's like those like
parasites that were like infected by the
t-virus but they're there they get up in
your face and they can basically plant
bugs inside your stomach and one of the
ways to stop that from happening because
that's a status condition is to eat an
herb and so yeah that's like one of the
big risks right you're in this infested
substation it was totally different it
was an interesting way to take on sort
of an event for the original and and and
expand it making it like this
interesting set piece that was spooky
and had me like really leaning on sort
of like my headphone audio to be like
are you come for the left or the right I
was behind me I don't know I think
you're in front of me I looked you're
scattering you're skittering over there
the corner if resi all three can
capitalize on that and and and kind of
feature those iconic moments while just
having all these different things in
between like man am I gonna be so
excited to just see what this is it's
it's it already seemed so promising just
based on some of the things that I've
been able to experience from it just in
the two hours that I've been playing
so resident evil 3 remake plays like
resin evil to remake right it's built on
the same engine the re engine but like
the original there's like an increase in
action right there's it's emphasized
that much more I mean cuz look you're
out on the city streets there are
zombies everywhere and so you kind of
have to literally use your ammo and your
resources a butt ton like it's just
there you are challenged to confront
enemies much more than you did in
resonable 2 we make you know we get more
ammo for example but another big
important addition this time around is
that you have a Dodge maneuver that
allows you to dodge in sort of any
direction in order to sort of jukka past
zombies this is also kind of cool
because if you time it correctly you can
do what's called a perfect dodge which
is got a little bit like the original
they had that kind of element in it but
that dodge mechanic from that game but
in this one when you do perfect dodge
zero will just like roll to the side and
then she'll like instantly like aim at a
zombie's head in slow motion it's kind
of like vanquish if you know that game
it's as you can kind of tell a lot more
action-oriented just in general across
the board that said even though there's
a emphasis on action it's still spooky
Resident Evil it's still hey we're not
gonna give you all the ammo like wasn't
evil to make you have to do a lot of
sort of risk reward management
decision-making as you're exploring this
hectic environment if anything the
action focus isn't so much that there's
just a butt ton of zombies you feel very
empowered it's that you are just
engaging with enemies more you're
engaging with having to deal with how am
I gonna get past this threat and so
that's what I mean it's elevated in that
sense it's it's less like let's go
through a hallway oh my god one zombie
how am I gonna get through this it's
more like oh my gosh I'm on the street
there are five zombies there and there's
a zombie over there and I think there's
one behind me
so I feel like this conversation
wouldn't be complete without talking
about the Nemesis which has returned
which is like ah mr. X like from resin
able to we make but more aggressive
nemesis you'll you'll come out
eventually has to be expected and he's
interesting because like mr. X he will
pursue you and try to hit you and try to
you know get in your face but the
difference is with mr. X there's evil to
remake you could mostly get past them
pretty easily right you know like oh I
see you over there
there's a desk I'm gonna run in this
direction good luck going around it I'm
gonna buy some time and get out of your
face was there a present evil 3 remake
nemesis is ridiculous and how fast he
can be he can catch up to you very
quickly in the sense of like you're just
running ahead and you think that like ah
yeah he's not gonna punch me
no he punches you
like when you see him and you choose to
run away he can instantly just like jump
right in front of you the moment you
tried to make a beeline for an exit and
it's ridiculous like he'll just knock
over zombies in front of you if they
happen to be in the path this is kind of
where the action also comes into play
right they're still managing your
resources but you're dealing with the
dude who you know to be honest you have
to you have to engage with him he is way
more aggressive he'll catch up to you
incredibly quickly and so this becomes a
part of the whole decision-making
process when you're fighting nemesis
it's a fun sort of mix a fun little sort
of iteration really on mr. X in the
sense of like you have to fight him
there are times when you know I was
confronted with this choice of like okay
I need to get to this train station
right now but he's in the way I need to
throw a grenade because like I can't
deal with this I'm running out of herbs
and first-aid sprays and ammo
so let us know in the comments below if
your is just as I am about resonable 3
remake and of course stay tuned for more
content around the game coming soon at
GameSpot once again I'm Matt thank you
for watching stars